alexie mchammond is forced from her job
as editor-in-chief of teen vogue for
tweets
from her teenage years democrats
continue to defend their rotten coveted
policy and the left continues to insist
that anti-asian racism is an outgrowth
of white supremacy alone
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
slash ben we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first a reminder you're
spending
way too much on that cell phone bill the
reason is a lot of phone companies will
intentionally attempt to confuse you as
to what exactly you're buying they'll
tell you you need things that you don't
actually need what you need is puretalk
usa which is the reason
that so many of my listeners have
abandoned their overpriced wireless
carriers and are flocking to pure talk
for the same coverage at a fraction of
the price that's right if you're with
verizon att or t-mobile switching to
pure talk could save your family over
a year switching is really easy you can
keep your phone keep your number or get
huge discounts on the latest iphones and
androids right now
you get unlimited talk text and six gigs
of data for just 30 bucks a month and if
you go over on the data they're not
going to charge you for it so what
exactly do you have to lose
there's a reason pure talk is the
highest rated wireless company by
consumer affairs
stop giving your money to overpriced
wireless carriers start saving money
today
from your cell phone dial pound 250 say
my name ben
shapiro you'll save 50 off your very
first month that is pound two five zero
say ben shapiro pure talk is simply
smarter wireless again you're spending
way too much on that cell phone bill
save hundreds of bucks a year head on
over to dialing pound 250
say ben shapiro save 50 off your very
first
month of cell coverage with pure talk
usa the best cell coverage
pure talk usa alrighty so we begin today
with the continuation of cancellation
the cancellations will continue until
morale improves so here's the thing
unless you are just pure as the driven
snow and i mean you haven't said
a word since you're a baby because we
know from
a wide variety of left-leaning studies
that babies begin to get racist around
three months i'm not kidding
these articles have been reported in nbc
news this means that basically the only
people
we should be allowing to have any sort
of influence in public life are people
who have not spoken a word
since they were capable of speaking
basically anybody who has spoken what
like
when you learned language as a toddler
when you were like 13 14 months old and
you really started to learn how to say
words
at that point you need to shut the hell
up you need to shut the hell up all the
way until you want to draw a teen vogue
that is the way
this now works is that nothing you say
is off-limits everything you have ever
said is gonna be held over your head
for all time because what we have
created in this country
is an arbitrary system of justice
whereby since everything is online and
since we can basically surveil
everything that you have ever said
we can always dig up something from your
past to hit you with we can oh
if you become inconvenient we can just
punish you
and see there's this this notion in law
that selective prosecution is a bad
thing
that if you're holding one person to a
standard and everybody else to a
different standard that that is unfair
but that is the way that our social
media social justice crowd works right
now
is that the standards are completely
arbitrary
they they the points don't matter and no
and and then we name a winner right
it's whose line is it anyway at any
given point we can go back into your
past pluck
a thing that you said and then we can
use it to hit you over the head even if
you've apologized for or explained it
away
10 million times and this is exactly
what happened to alexia mccammon now
listen
some of us here on the right are willing
to defend people on the left or in the
center
who get cancelled for no reason other
than the animus and spite
of a bunch of woke staffers who have
decided that they are the purity police
and have decided they don't want this
particular person in power at this
particular time because make no mistake
this is not about a principled stand
that
anyone who has ever said anything bad
must be ousted because we've all said
things that are bad we all have bad
social media posts if you've been online
for more than a couple of years
the chances that you have said something
at some point that is unpleasant
are really really high in fact if you've
ever used email
or text messages if you've ever been on
whatsapp if you've ever ever been
on like a group board if you've ever
done any of those things the chances
that you have said something that could
be taken out of context or
misinterpreted or that you actually said
something bad
are 193 because we're all human and we
all sin
as it says in ecclesiastes we have all
sinned every single one of us
okay but we have a society where we can
arbitrarily choose
which sins to bring up at any given time
and then we can choose to just destroy
you so this is what just happened to
alexi mccammon now alexa mccammon is not
a member of the right alexia mccammon
is a member of the left alexa mccammon
was hired
by teen vogue specifically because they
said they wanted to make their their
editorial page and their editorial
oversight more diverse alexa mccammon is
a black woman
well now she's been ousted from her java
teen vogue because a bunch of 23 year
old woke staffers decided
that tweets that she sent when she was a
freshman in college
okay like 10 years ago when that she
said when she was a freshman in college
are bad and racist and they are they're
not good tweets but that this is an
excuse
for now denying her a career promotion
and this is usually how it works
well usually alexa mccammon wasn't
cancelled when she was over at axios
alexa mccammon wasn't canceled when she
was reporting stories from the white
house
alexie mccammon was cancelled when she
felt when she felt that she had reached
the apex of her career thus far
the same thing happened with kevin hart
in other words keep your head down
try not to get any level of career
advancement the moment that you advance
a little bit that is when they club you
all right same thing with gina carano as
soon as gina cronin hits the mandalorian
suddenly the hate comes out
as soon as chris pratt is doing
guardians of the galaxy that's when all
the hate comes out
the higher you rise in your career the
more people want to tear you down
and so they will just bring up anything
from the past in an attempt to smear you
and destroy you and it doesn't matter
again
whether you've repented because we are
not a culture of repentance we're a
culture of graceless jackassery
according to the new york times alexie
mccammon who made her name as a politics
reporter at the washington news site
axios had planned to start as the
editor-in-chief of teen vogue next
wednesday
now after teen vogue staff members
publicly condemned racist and homophobic
tweets ms mccombett had posted a decade
ago
she has resigned from the job content
asked is teen vogue's publisher they
announced the abrupt turn on thursday in
an internal email that was sent amid
pressure
from the publication staff readers and
at least two advertisers just two weeks
after the company had appointed her
to the position so alexa mccammon put
out a statement
about this so did hr obviously because
you always have to have a statement from
hr
alexi mccammon's statement was an
announcement
of course that she had that
that she was no longer going to be the
editor in chief of teen vogue
she wrote quote i became a journalist to
help lift up stories and voices of our
most vulnerable communities
again she's not a member of the right as
a young woman of color that's part of
the reason i was so excited to lead the
teen vogue team
in this next chapter my past tweets have
overshadowed the work i've done to
highlight the people and issues i care
about
issues that teen vogue has worked so
tirelessly to share with the world first
of all
does anyone understand the irony of teen
vogue which is the teen version of a
fashion magazine like a high fashion
magazine
deciding that they are now the moral
police
teen vogue that's where you go for your
political
morality teen vogue which writes pieces
every few days about how socialism is
wonderful
okay condensed and i have decided to
part ways has alex mccammon i should not
have tweeted what i did and i have taken
full responsibility for that i look at
my work
and growth in the year since and have
redoubled my commitment to growing in
the years to come
as a person and as a professional i wish
the talented team at teen vogue the
absolute best moving forward their work
has never been more important i will be
rooting for them there are so many
stories left to be told especially
about marginalized communities and the
issues affecting them i hope to have the
opportunity to rejoin the ranks of
tireless journalists who are shining
light on the issues that matter
every single day okay so we'll see
who hires her next because apparently
advertisers are so afraid of this
they're so cowed by the woke staffers
that they are deeply concerned
that if alexia mccammon were to edit
teen vogue and they would be associated
with that person
then they would lose what their consumer
base
the sheer cowardice of people in
institutional power and the sheer
brazenness
of all the woke staffers who decide that
they get to decide who their bosses are
is pretty
impressive again if a bunch of employees
at the daily wire
came to me and they were like you know
what we don't like the stuff that you've
been saying on your show
and so you're supposed to now fire
yourself my answer would be
no that's not your job the teen vogue
publisher should have said to the woke
staffers guess what you don't get to
appoint the eic i get to appoint the eic
but all of these companies are so afraid
of their own staff and they're so afraid
they're going to be accused in other
media outlets of being racist and
terrible
they're so afraid they just fired a
black editor okay alexi mccammon is a
black woman
that didn't save her because she crossed
swords with the woke because the woke
decided they didn't like her enough
cons and asked their hr department put
out an entire statement and said
hi everyone yashika odin our chief
diversity and inclusion officer again
the chief diversity and inclusion
officer is the most orwellian title
in all of american corporate life
because it's not about inclusion or
about diversity certainly not on an
ideological level it's about complete
corporate conformity
rams down from the absolute top that is
what the chief diversity and inclusion
officer always is and it's a billion
dollar industry
in multi-billion dollars and as of 1990
or something we're spending 8 billion
on diversity initiatives at these
various companies now it's got to be a
multiple of that obviously
yashika olden our chief diversity and
inclusion officer i.e a professional
useless person and i have had
conversations with many of you over the
past week
we know this has been a challenging time
for so many really was it a challenge
was it a super challenging time that you
read a tweet that was 10 years old from
a freshman in college
and you thought to yourself god my life
is ruined why don't i just get rid of
this person
our most important work as a company
right now is embodied in the focused
efforts we are all undertaking to become
more equitable and inclusive by
equitable
and inclusive they mean not inclusive
and we need to fire somebody
our commitment to these issues is
sincere and unwavering
it is fair to say that alexie mccammon's
appointment with teen vogue brought many
difficult and important conversations to
the forefront over the last few weeks
i want to be fully transparent with you
about our decision-making process
regarding her appointment
when alexi was a teenager she made
racially charged statements on social
media about asian people
well actually was straightforward and
transparent about these posts during our
interview process
and through public apologies years ago
okay so that should be the end of the
conversation
it's one thing if the company says i was
sandbag right i had no idea that this
stuff was out there
and now that i found out well that
changes the math but they knew
she had dealt with it in the interview
process and this company was still so
pusillanimous still so cowardly they
decided to dump her on the side of the
road
after saying yeah we see what you did
and we accept
your your explanation and your apology
and the fact that you've grown over time
it's it's amazing amazing stuff right so
they're they're actually reversing
their own grace that they've given this
woman given her previously uh her given
her previous acknowledgements of these
posts and her sincere apologies in
addition to her remarkable work in
journalism elevating the voices of
marginalized communities
by the way all of that kind of stuff
where they talk about journalism
elevating the voice of the marginalized
that is an ideological goal right
journalism is usually covering the news
but now you are considered a good
journalist if you are ideologically
driven to cover certain stories at the
expense of other stories but that is a
side point
they say we were looking forward to
welcoming welcoming her into our
community
in addition we were hopeful that alexi
would become part of our team to provide
perspective and insight that is
underrepresented throughout media
we were dedicated to making her
successful in this role and spent time
working with her our company leadership
and the teen vogue team to find the best
path forward to that end
after speaking with lexi this morning we
agreed it was best to part ways so as to
not overshadow the important work
happening at teen vogue
again all that important work you need
that important work about
various sexual positions as well as the
the latest in lady gaga's makeup i'm
including the note she shared on twitter
today
as always the people team and i are here
to support you and answer any and all
questions you may have
thank you for your patience with us
thank you for your patience with us what
patience
we're available to meet with you and
your teams to continue these important
conversations uh amazing amazing stuff
from hr
again it's a it's a graceless terrible
society and the cancellations will
continue until morale improves now
i gotta tell you as a conservative i'm
rooting for the cancellation i'm rooting
for the counselors
i'm i'm rooting for the counselors at
this point i hope that they cancel
everybody
on the left side of the aisle so they
learn that cancellation is bad
okay because if they got to burn down
the village in order to save the village
go for it guys
i'm rooting for you i'm here for you you
guys want to cancel a bunch of decent
people
who are attempting to do good work
because you are graceless jerks
guess what plenty of room on this side
of the aisle for you you want to count
you want to wish everybody out in the
corn field eventually they're going to
be enough of us here out in the
cornfield that we vastly outnumber you
okay so you want to continue doing this
you're just going to open business
opportunities for those of us who do not
accept
the fundamental basis of the nonsense
you are now proposing
you want to keep canceling gina carano
i'll just hire her
you want to cancel a bunch of
journalists we'll hire them
you woke corporations decide that you
want to cater to your woke base
we'll just form corporations that are
not woke and we'll and we'll cater to a
much broader and more diverse base
ideologically and racially speaking
probably
just keep doing it guys just keep it up
you're doing great you're making america
a better place
one cancellation at a time and then they
what's amazing is that these people
actually think that they're making the
country more pure
they probably do i mean i'm gonna grant
them the purity of their intent
or is it just that they have nothing
better to do and their lives are empty
the people who spend their days trolling
the internet for bad old comments to
cancel people
their their lives are empty they have no
sense of community they have no sense of
grace because they don't actually deal
with human beings they just deal with
people online
and they go for the retweets and the
clicks and so the goal is the
destruction
of other human beings for fun and profit
guess what at a certain point the fun
stops being fun
and you're gonna make those of us who
are not on the side of the counselors
the actual profitable ones just keep
doing it
just keep doing it you're stuffing money
in the pocket to your political
opponents you're giving us all political
credibility
so i hope that this continues and i hope
the democratic party continues to cater
to it i hope the folks at teen vogue
continue to do this sort of stuff
because eventually it's just gonna be
the woke talking to themselves
that that is the choice that they made
by the way the way this works is that
the only way alexi mccammon could have
gotten out of this presumably was not
only to apologize for her past
commentary
but to have joined the borg to have
assimilated to the borg and found them
another target
for them to attack right don't don't
kill me kill that person over there but
alexia mccammon didn't do that
or maybe it didn't matter maybe no
matter what she did they were gonna take
her down
and the fact that you have now brought
me to the point where i've now defended
over the past few years
sarah zhang who's awful alexia mccammon
with whom i wildly disagree
james gunn who i wildly disagree with
and is in favor of cancel culture and is
awful
i i i will defend people from having
their lives ruined because these rules
are not rules that anybody can live by
but if the left continues to live by
these rules
they're gonna alienate everybody and
good good i hope they do continue this i
hope they alienate
everybody okay meanwhile coveted policy
continues to be
a contentious issue it is amazing to see
the
biden administration continue to
downplay simultaneously up play the
success that they've had on
vaccine distribution and downplay the
actual effectiveness of the vaccines
it's kind of a weird combo because on
the one hand they want to say that
biden's done a wonderful job trenching
out the vaccines
which the administration has done fine
i'm not going to understand they've done
horribly
they haven't done like amazing again by
the end of february they were supposed
to have 100 federal mass vaccination
sites they had seven
it's the states that have been doing all
the heavy lifting with regard to the
vaccinations
but they've been talking up joe biden's
performance on covet at the same time
they've been saying that we have to wear
masks until the end of time because
you know the vaccines might not solve
all the problems and and all of this
they've been saying the schools have to
remain closed but the schools can kind
of open but they should remain closed
their covered policy in other words has
been a bag of garbage but they want it
both ways we're doing a great job on
coven and also kovid still haunts the
land which is why you need us
now here's the thing in order to promote
that they have to promote a bunch of bad
signs so yesterday
senator rand paul from kentucky he
questioned the great and glorious dr
anthony fauci second best doctor in
america after dr joe biden who of course
will diagnose you with a need for a
junior college degree should you have a
heart attack
dr anthony fauci appearing in front of
rand paul's committee
and rand paul points out that once you
are vaccinated once
you've gone through the vaccinations and
once you have had covet then wearing a
mask is essentially theater
that you are wearing a mask because it
makes other people feel comfortable
but the reality is that if you want
people to get the vaccine if you want to
cut down on vaccine hesitancy what you
tell people is
you can go back to regular life after
you've had both doses of the vaccine in
your two weeks past the last dose
he's right he's absolutely right rand
paul in this exchange is 100 correct and
dr anthony fauci is wrong
scientifically speaking rand paul is i
checked the work
okay so i went to dr marty mccary
frequent guest on the program from johns
hopkins university
he's written in the wall street journal
he was a member of of
several prior administrations and i said
in this exchange who was right fauci or
paul
he said voucher's just wrong okay so the
case that you're about to hear
rand paul make is that once you're
vaccinated and or once you've had covet
you now have immunity right you are now
immune
we don't know how long the immunity
lasts but we do know that the immunity
is pretty damn good
and there is no countervailing data
that's just widespread second infections
and so once you do that why are we
worried about you wearing a mask
we shouldn't care whether you wear a
mask at that point and he says tim you
know dr
fauci what you're doing is just for show
right you've been vaccinated
so why exactly are you double masking
it's just pretend
at this point and fouchy's answer which
is that there might still be variants
out there
is a is a is an answer without a
limiting principle
it's like saying sometime in the future
an asteroid could hit earth so we better
prepare for it now
okay well i mean how by wearing a mask
every single day
he says that there could be variants
that come along that are really bad yes
and there could be a brand new pandemic
tomorrow that could be really bad so
maybe we should just keep wearing masks
forever
the point that he is making is not
scientifically correct the vaccines have
been extraordinarily resilient
against most of the virtually all of the
variants there is one single situation i
believe in brazil
in a very small area where there was a
variant that did not end up spreading
beyond that
that had some secondary infections but
there is very little evidence at this
point at all
to see in fact no major study as rand
paul points out that suggests
that if you're vaccinated or if you've
had covet then you should be deeply
worried about a second wave
of covid from a variant so why are you
wearing a mask here's rand paul pointing
this this out to fouchy and fauci
getting angry that he's being called on
the carpet what studies do you have
that people that have had the vaccine or
have had the infection
are spreading the infection if we're not
spreading the infection isn't it just
theater no it's not a vaccine and you're
wearing two masks isn't that
theater no that's not here we go again
with the theater let's get down to the
facts
in the south african study conducted
by j and j they found that people who
were infected
with wild type and were exposed to the
variant in south africa the 351
it was as if they had never been
infected before
they had no protection okay except
for the fact that when these south
african variants have hit europe
when they've hit the united states in
places where there's max fascinating
mass vaccination you're not seeing
secondary infections
right there is no evidence in the united
states at all
and as far as i'm aware no evidence in
europe that there has been widespread
secondary infection of people who have
already been infected with covid from
the variants
right the variants are in fact variants
okay they are
they some of them spread faster some of
them are apparently more deadly
but vaccination has thus far been
extraordinarily resilient
to that and if you've already had covet
the the generalized notion that the
variants are now going to reinfect you
and kill you
maybe you get reinfected but the the
severity of the infection is another
matter that matters here the masks are
in fact theater at this point if you've
already been vaccinated
and yet you have the entire
administration saying that you're
supposed to wear the mask until when
there's no end point here because a
variant could arise literally at any
point along the line
again there's no limiting principle here
that's what's so weird about the
position
that this administration is taking they
have to justify their policy they have
to justify
masking until the end of time they have
to justify lockdowns jay bhattacharya
from stanford university
yesterday he depressor and he points out
lockdowns have not stopped the spread he
did this pressure with governor ron
desantis in florida
international evidence and the the
american evidence is clear
there's uh the lockdowns have not
stopped the spread of the disease
in any any measurable way the
the disease spreads
by aerosol by droplets it's a it's a
respiratory disease it's very difficult
to stop
the idea of the lockdown is incredibly
i mean in some ways beguiling so if you
just stay apart far enough
like rats in cages we won't spread the
disease
but humans are not like that okay and
that is exactly right
what you've seen is the places that did
lockdown like new york or like
california they got hit just as hard as
places that didn't lock down in some
case
in some cases significantly harder by
the way how unscientific
is the biden administration the cdc is
now revising its guidelines on cova
distancing they're supposed to do that
today
they're supposed to point out that in
classrooms kids can be three feet apart
we just spent a year doing six feet
apart for no reason at all
so when people say follow the science
what they really mean is just listen to
experts who tell you stuff that's not
based on the science that's where fouchy
comes in and and then they wonder why
people have doubt in our scientific
institutions if you can't explain the
science
then you're doing a bad job end of story
okay meanwhile the entire media has
decided that this shooting in atlanta is
once again evidence of america's
widespread white supremacy which is a
weird take
considering again we have no evidence at
this point that the
accused gunman the alleged gunman that
this piece of crap
targeted the women because of race
we have fairly good evidence at this
point that he targeted these particular
places because they were
they were sex shops that he had visited
before according to the new york times
he checked himself into a rehab clinic
for a self-described sexual addiction he
was so intense on avoiding pornography
he blocked websites from his computer
and only used a flip phone
he worried to a roommate about falling
out of god's grace months before the
shooter we don't mention shooters names
on the show was charged with carrying
out a bloody rampage of three massage
parlors that horrified the nation and
stoked a furious outcry over anti-asian
violence
the 21 year old suspect who'd grown up
in a conservative baptist church
appeared fixated on guilt
and lust he said the new york times is
saying this is about sex addiction
it's about guilt and lust by all of the
available evidence
and presumably the new york times also
thinks this is about religion because if
religion didn't make you feel so guilty
about your
your guilt and lost then you wouldn't do
this sort of stuff which is a
pretty extraordinary claim as
investigators on thursday pieced
together whether and how racism and
sexism
might have motivated tuesday's attacks
people who knew the shooter offered new
details about a dangerous collision of
sexual loathing and what a former
roommate described as religious mania
that marked his life in the years before
the shooting spree
this guy went to a church that strictly
prohibited sex outside of marriage was
distraught by his failed attempts to
curb his sexual urges
set a former roommate nearly once a
month he would admit he'd again relapse
by visiting a
massage parlor for sex said to the
roommate he once asked
the roommate to take his computer away
from him atlanta police said on thursday
that the shooter had been a customer at
two spas in the city that were targeted
in the attacks that killed eight people
overall including six women of asian
descent
did not specify whether he had sought
anything more than a massage at the two
businesses
aromatherapy spa and gold spa both of
which appear on sort of sex
place listings online apparently
apparently when the shooter was arrested
he said he was on his way to florida to
carry out another attack on a business
tied to the pornography industry he's
been charged with eight counts of murder
okay so
it seems pretty obvious that this is
chiefly not about reyes
right that what this is chiefly about is
this guy's perverse views on on sex his
blaming
women in the sex trade for his own
inability to control himself
and it seems like and there are plenty
of issues to discuss there
the sexualization of american culture
how people deal with with things like
pornography addiction which is a very
real thing where the blame ought to lie
how we how we deal with that in
a society that the champions the virtues
of sexual profligacy
there are all sorts of issues to discuss
here but race is
pretty low on the on the evidence
on the evidence-based issues to discuss
again there's not a lot of evidence
that this guy was doing this because he
hated asian people there's a fair bit of
evidence that he was doing this because
he hated
sex workers right that he hated
massage shops that were actually
brothels
now the atlanta police have come under a
lot of fire because the atlanta police
have just reported what this guy said
here is the the deputy police chief
charles hampton
saying that he doesn't have a position
on whether it was hate crime or not
because they literally have no evidence
at this point it was a hate crime
the investigation into a possible hate
crime that's still on the table
our investigation is looking at
everything so nothing is off the table
for our investigation
what is apd's position on that
i don't have a position like i said i
got i'm only going to comment about
our investigation uh and again we're
we're not prepared to talk a lot about
uh what has been said
uh because again we're not trying to uh
try the case in public but the media are
hungry for a narrative how hungry are
they for a narrative
there is a police spokesperson yesterday
who did a presser on this
and talked about how the suspect had
said that he had a really bad day
right that's what the suspect said he
didn't say i think he had a really bad
day he said the suspect
told us that he had a really bad day so
he was narrating what the suspect had
said
there's a jackass online and darren
rupar he is a terrible terrible source
of misinformation he frequently cuts
things out of context and then just puts
them up
he put up the clip as though the police
chief the police spokesperson was making
the claim
that this guy had a really bad day and
somehow this justified the murders
that is not true i mean it's overtly not
true if you just look at the entirety of
the clip
that he took out of context what you'll
see is that the police spokesperson
was relaying what the suspect had said
the blowback against the police officer
was so strong that people were calling
for his firing
people are saying the police officer
should be fired fired for even narrating
the words
of what the suspect had told them
because the narrative is obvious right
the narrative
is that this was anti-asian animus that
was an anti-asian hate crime and the
reason the media are intent
and focusing on this particular story as
an anti-asian hate crime
is because their narrative is anytime
there is hate and it can be tied to
broader american quote unquote whiteness
then then we can talk about racial
hatred if it's hatred between blacks and
nations
you can't talk about that at all that is
an unmentionable thing
yes no i want to make a correction on
yesterday's show so yesterday's show i
talked about violent crime statistics by
community
and i pointed out that violent crime
statistics by community if you look
at the victimizers of asian people in
violent crime
it was disproportionately black people
who were targeting asian people in crime
now
that was not hate crime statistics okay
so that could just be casual crime that
could just be a black person robbed an
asian person or something
when i say disproportionate i mean that
about 24 of all crimes committed against
asians or by asians about 24
are are committed by whites against
stations and about 25 percent are
committed by black people against asians
but that's normal everyday crime i mean
that's that's not necessarily racially
motivated
so i want to correct the record on that
okay because that was wrong
the information was incorrect what we do
know is that according to the fbi
statistics
there were more than 4 000 hate crimes
in the united states in 2019
about 4.4 percent of those were
committed against asian americans
which amounts to about 220
crimes against asian americans they
don't give the source of the crimes so
we don't actually know who is committing
the hate crimes against asian americans
but we have no evidence
by the same token to suggest that it is
quote unquote white supremacy that is
responsible for the uptick in anti-asian
violence
and the anecdotal evidence shows that
there's been a pretty significant spike
in violent crime
including in the major cities that that
are not being done by white people
predominantly
right if you if you look at a major
crime uptick in new york city there's
been a major murder uptick in new york
city major murder uptick
in los angeles if you look at that you
wouldn't automatically say well that's
an alcohol of white supremacy that'd be
a weird take so if you say there's been
an elevated level
of crime in new york city against asian
americans or in los angeles against
asian americans and your first take is
that's white supremacy
these cities are extremely racially
diverse these cities are very much to
the left
the the notion that you had a bunch of
red-hatted maga trolls
who you know people who are like well
you know he said chinese virus i'm going
to go target a chinese person today
that's what's been happening in
america's major cities which is where
most of the spike is happening
kind of a weird take certainly
evidence-free there's no basis for in
evidence for that but the narrative must
be promulgated at all costs because the
narrative is always the same
america broadly writ is to blame and
america broadly writ is a white
supremacist country
and thus any bad thing that happens is
attributable to the white supremacy i've
even seen the argument that even if it
is disproportionately
black people who are harming
asian-american people in the united
states that that is an outgrowth of
white supremacy because our white
supremacist system
has forced conflict between minorities
it's the the atheists will talk about
how religious people
who don't know how to defend their
religion will kind of use the god of the
gaps argument we don't know why x
happened therefore god
okay there is a racism of the gaps
argument a white supremacy of the gaps
argument that is frequently used
not not just frequently ubiquitously
used by the left
something bad happens therefore racism
of the gaps right white supremacy of the
gaps we don't know why there's been this
uptick
in anti-asian crime white supremacy it
must be white supremacy must be trump
must be a bunch of things
that i don't like it can it can never be
the possibility
that maybe there's a disproportionate
amount of minority on minority violence
in this particular situation which by
the way again if you look at the overall
crime statistics there is
a disproportionate amount of black on
asian violence just by percentages of
population okay we'll get some more of
this in just one second because this
also goes to which kind of stories are
ignored by the media and which kind of
stories
are covered by the media and how exactly
the media cover these stories
the the broader point here which is that
the media are blaming
the right wing for this without any
evidence whatsoever at this point
that's undeniable the editorial board at
the new york times says asian americans
are scared for a reason
bigotry and demagoguing have pushed
communities close to a crisis point
so the suggestion of course is once
again that it was
donald trump that is responsible for the
uptick in anti-asian crime
even though the uptick in anti-asian
crime is happening almost entirely
in large metropolitan blue areas after a
year of vitriol and violence against
asian americans amid the coronavirus
pandemic
it's long past time to admit the country
has a problem a year ago this month
after the pandemic had already
established a beachhead in the united
states this board wrote
there's a long history of diseases
triggering waves of violence against
jews during the black death right
through the animus
linked to ebola sars and zika chinese
americans and other asians lumped
together with them by racist are beings
beaten spat on yelled at insulted from
coast to coast
the president then was donald trump mr
trump said china virus again
this week during a fox news interview
there is no evidence that this was
driven
by trump saying china virus okay and by
the way
the virus did come from china that is
not an anti-asian sentiment
that's asinine that's like saying that
the south african variant of the virus
should be blamed on south africans or
the brazilian variants the virus should
be blamed on brazilians
it's just a location the spanish flu it
does not mean that you're supposed to be
a racist against people who originate
from spain
and again there's no evidence to suggest
that this is a result of trump saying
china virus over and over and over
but the message has to be promulgated
and this is a broader
this is a broader problem our media are
basically now saying
that any time a crime is committed by a
white person against a person of another
race
the answer must be racism but if a crime
is committed
by a minority against a person of
another race then the answer is also
white supremacy but by extension
you've created a completely
unfalsifiable thesis here we'll get some
more of this in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that there
are medical conditions that people have
and very often they just want to ignore
them they kind of hope that they just go
away but here's the thing medical
conditions don't just
go away with roman you get a free online
evaluation and ongoing care for erectile
dysfunction all from the comfort and
privacy
of your home a u.s licensed healthcare
professional will work with you to find
the best treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it trips you free
with two-day shipping the whole process
is straightforward and discreet getting
started is super simple just go to
getroman.com ben
complete an online visit today take care
of your ed without
without leaving your home complete an
online visit today to connect with a
healthcare professional and get it taken
care of
today go to getroman.com right now
you'll get 15 bucks
off your very first month it's really
time to get your ed taken care of
remember get started today you'll save
15 bucks on your first order
of ed treatment go to getroman.com ben
today a lot of chronic medical
conditions people just sort of hope they
go away they never do
or very rarely do they so this is why
you should go get it treated you can do
it discreetly
and easily and inexpensively go to
getromand.com right now
you get 15 bucks off your first month of
ed treatment getroman.com
ben alrighty folks it is that glorious
glorious
time of the week when i give a shout out
to a daily ware member today it is
marissa on instagram who knows you need
the right energy fuel to help tackle
today's parenting tasks in this picture
marissa is donning sunglasses and
clutching the world's greatest beverage
vessel while waiting patiently in her
vehicle the caption reads
when your daily wire ben shapiro tumblr
comes in the mail just in time to pick
up the kids from school hashtag leftist
years tumblr
fantastic glad we could help thanks for
the picture and for being a daily ware
member
also there's a lot of buzz in the air
here at the daily wire candace owens
filmed the first episode of her new show
this week it's all anyone in the office
can talk about it looks fantastic
candace does an amazing job folks
you're going to love the show but you
have to be a member candice
from yours today it's going to be unlike
any other daily weather show you've seen
before
if you want a sneak peek of your new
show and honestly why would you not
check out canada's owns and the rest of
the daily wire gang and last night's
special edition of backstage we
discussed candace's new show as well as
all the big picture issues affecting our
nation
namely joe biden's horrifying
accomplishments and cardi b's
extraordinary grammy performance don't
forget candace it premieres today
it's exclusive to daily wire members
it's awesome it looks great it's
something you've never
seen before if you aren't a member yet
be sure to join now to make sure you
don't miss a single episode of candace
go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace for 25 off
that is dailywire.com
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
now remember all of this is a broader
argument by the left and that broader
argument by the left
is if a white person does a bad thing
that is reflective of american racism
and white supremacy
and whiteness more generally and we can
impute intent
without actually showing evidence of
intent right this does tie back into the
general cancel culture idea
which is that if the it's the impact of
your words that matters not
why you said it or what you did so this
sort of
thought has sort of seeped in this sort
of strict liability notion
of how we ought to treat fellow human
beings this has this has seeped into
every area of our discord so trevor noah
over on comedy central who i mean i i
used to
it's in the name of the network comedy
central but i'm just wondering where the
comedy went
now it's just central so trevor noah he
says
the the atlanta shooter is clearly
operating from racist premises now
here's the thing again i don't know
whether he's a racist
maybe he is maybe he is he's crap either
way it turns out you don't have to be a
racist to be a complete piece of crap
there are lots of people who are awful
evil people
who are not in fact driven primarily by
race or racial animus
happens all the time there are lots of
people who commit evil horrifying crimes
against members of their own race they
are evil and horrifying
but since the great sin in america is
not actually doing things that are evil
but being a racist
there is only one type of sin that lies
at the root of all other sin in any case
here is trevor noah making the strict
liability case which is if you are a
member of
if you are a white person and you heard
a non-white person we do not even have
to investigate intent
the actions themselves are racist so we
don't even have to listen to what you
have to say
in order for us to impute your action to
all of america
her background her history and her
institutions one of the first things
that's been the most frustrating for me
is
seeing the shooter say oh it wasn't
racism it was sex addiction first of all
you man
you killed six asian people specifically
you went there if there's anyone who's
racist it's a mother
who kills six asian women your murders
speak louder than your words
six asian women were killed okay so your
murderers speak louder than words okay
so by his standard
by his standard which is your your
actions speak louder than your words we
can impute racist intent
then i can by trevor no standard go back
to the stats i was using yesterday
in which some 27 percent of all violent
crimes committed against asian americans
are committed by black americans
a wildly outsized number more asian
americans are victimized in violent
crime by black americans than by members
of any other race
now earlier i corrected the record
because i said i don't know if those are
racially motivated or whether they're
not whether they're just street crime
but according to trevor noah i don't
even have to do that
i can say that because black americans
target asian americans for crime at
outsized rates that must mean
that that isn't that is racial hatred
that is driving it
now i can do that by his standard except
i can't because the standard only works
this way
with white people it only works this way
with white people according to the left
which is why it is not a major national
news story when two
black teenagers light a mentally ill man
on fire
and let him die in rochester new york
now you know if the races were reversed
this would not only be a national news
story it would be the only national news
story
if there were two white teenagers 16 and
14 and they'd found a mentally ill black
man
and then they had set him on fire in his
own home and burned him to death
that would certainly be not only a
national news story it would be it would
spread a thousand thing pieces
about what kind of culture could create
kids who would do such a thing
how the ingrained history of 400 years
of racism in america had led
to this sort of evil as it is you've
never even heard this story
i mean it's not a national news story
this is one of the things you'll find
wonderful about our establishment media
they get to decide what a national news
story is and what a national news story
is not it is not a national news story
every weekend when
a dozen people get shot to death in
chicago it is a national news story
if a white person says a mean thing to a
black person and it's caught on tape
because again the narrative is more
important than what actually is the news
by the way here is that story from
rochester new york is according to
amanda presta giacomo
two black teens have been charged with
assault and arson in connection to the
brutal death of a mentally ill white man
in rochester new york the two reportedly
sneaked into the home of the man on
friday afternoon
sprayed him with an ignitable fluid and
set him on fire until 70 percent of his
body was covered in second and
third-degree burns
a man identified as either a mail
carrier or a gas and electric worker
burst into the apartment to try to
put out the burning man who was
apparently left to die by the time the
911 call was made and police arrived it
was too late the victim fought for his
life for four days in a burn trauma unit
before he passed
the story was reported here here's how
the media treat this stuff right
the story was reported by local station
wham 13 news
but the races of the individuals
involved were not specified
rochester journalist and radio host bob
lonsberry made the races public and
highlighted
the double standard in news coverage
that has contributed to the
deterioration of rochester a city
engulfed and at times violent campaign
against police officers over alleged
racism
citing law enforcement sources lonsbury
reports the teens instructed the victim
during the incident
to tell authorities it was two white men
who perpetrated the crime
a police source confirmed lonsbury's
reporting to the daily wire
again the races were considered
irrelevant when this was reported
by wham 13 in rochester is there any
circumstance
any circumstance where the races were
reversed or where
white teens had burned death an asian
person or
any minority person for that matter and
this is not a national news story that
leads the nightly news
every night for several weeks any
situation of course not
of course that is the chief news story
but if it's a white person you impute
this is the rule of the left these days
if it's a white person you impute intent
intent matters if it does not matter if
it's a white person and
if it's a minority person who does
something terrible to a white person
or a black person who does something
terrible to a nation person then we try
to brush that under the rug a little bit
because the only racism that matters is
of cour rate is of course racism
combined with power now what's amazing
about this is the entire argument is
that racism combined with power is true
racism
this is the argument you'll hear from
the radical racial left
that racism is not just animus about
other racial groups it is that combined
with
institutional power but who actually has
the institutional power
when the only narrative that you are
allowed to promulgate is this narrative
who that's the irony who is the actual
institutional power here
when certain types of crime get brushed
under the rug as racialized crime
and other types of crime that there's no
evidence are racially based
are treated as racial crimes who has the
institutional power and that narrative
is not only promulgated but if you deny
the narrative you're considered out of
the mainstream
and crazy and terrible and racist by the
way who has the actual institutional
power here
it is not these supposed white
supremacists who run the system is it
and it's pr the the treatment of these
cases the disparate treatment
is pretty telling and the media are just
gonna repeat this stuff over and over
and over again
so cnn's lisa ling she went on the air
and she said americans are always
scapegoating minorities that's what
that's what americans do
that americans are constantly
scapegoating minorities
um no actually and if we're gonna talk
about scapegoating
minorities you can't say all americans
right because
that breaks the leftist taboo again
saying that some americans of minority
status might victimize other americans
minority status
if you're going to talk about americans
blaming minorities you might want to
talk about the left which literally says
that we have to shut down merit-based
high schools because too many asians are
doing well
and that we should have discriminatory
admissions policies into major
universities because asians are doing
too well
that's not the narrative you're gonna
hear on cnn on cnn it is wonderful and
progressive
to bar asian americans from
high-performing high schools and in fact
you shut down the high schools entirely
as they're doing in new york and san
francisco
but it is anti-asian if you can find no
evidence
that somebody did something that's
that's anti-asian per se did something
evil but
no evidence yet that it's anti-asian
specifically that's it one of those
things is anti-asian one of those things
is clearly not but it's not
what the media are telling you here is
the uh here is lisa ling
again blaming america for all of us
asian people are being scapegoated
like they have for a century in this
country
and and this has to stop this has to
stop we cannot be continued
to be scapegoated and and this is
frankly a pattern of scapegoating that
happens in this country
yesterday it was muslim and southeastern
asian people after 9 11.
when there's an economic downturn it's
the latin population
uh you know it's always the black
community being scapegoated for so many
things
and during the cold war it was gay
people this scapegoating of entire
populations
has to stop in this country okay you
noticed something
i'm just gonna notice something right
there that narrative is so
her final line does not comport with
everything else that she has said there
the scapegoating of entire populations
has to stop in this country
and then she names a bunch of people who
have been victimized by the american
system
right asians gay people black people
latinos you noticing one group that
is never mentioned here ever ever ever
ever white people of course
right those are the victimizers in all
those circumstances it's white people
who are the victimizers
what if not every story comports with
that what if it turns out the vast
majority of white people
are not racist what if it turns out the
american meritocracy
is not racist in fact it is the american
meritocracy that has led to asian
americans being the highest earning
income group in the united states
but so long as the narrative is the
narrative it must be preserved at all
costs
intent doesn't matter evidence doesn't
matter only only the narrative matters
which is why you have olivia munn
on national television saying that a
sheriff from atlanta who is just
repeating the words of the suspect
ought to lose his job first of all i
don't know why olivia munn is an expert
on this i mean she's a person of asian
ancestry but i assume they could have
found like an actual political expert of
asian ancestry turns out there are many
of them
here's olivia munn on msnbc
to hear this captain
actually tried to humanize the shooter
in this way it act it just dehumanizes
all of the victims and and then to find
out that he had been posting
racist facebook posts about uh blaming
the pandemic on china
i don't even know how this guy still has
a job it's just mind-boggling but it
makes so much sense once you see
where he stands he is a racist and
he shouldn't have that job how can he
protect and serve all of us
when he clearly has viewpoints that he
hates
a large portion of us okay she literally
has no evidence of this the entire
evidence that this police staffer is
apparently a bad guy
this police captain is that he wore a
shirt that's a china virus
that's the entirety of it and he was not
defending the shooter he was literally
just relating what the shooter said
it was taken out of context and they
called for his head because again
you notice the the race on that police
officer that's that's the way
that it works in the united states
intense is not necessary to impute
racism to white people
in the united states my view is
consistent if you can show
racist intent that is an act of racist
evil
but you require evidence you require
intent and you don't get to attribute to
the
entire american quote-unquote white
supremacist system crimes that are
committed by specific people
without an actual explanation of how
that happened or why that happened or
how that occurred in the first place
the left doesn't need evidence all they
need is just the talking point
all right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content first
you cannot forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's show is every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you so
head on over to dailywire.com this
evening at 7 pm eastern and tune in i'm
ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavel wydowski
editing is by adam sci events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way through the fall of the
republic with me
andrew clavin